[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to PJ's cake
class we're gonna talk about something
really simple today it's not really
about how to model but it's a little bit
tricking tips for the rendering as you
can see I have a stone with the prong
set over there now if you look at the
top view and if it is a ring 80% of the
designs on the top view then you can see
I don't see the metal around a stone the
reason I do that is because the stone
will look bigger in this way now let's
take a look on the front view it's just
a concept of the song setting I'm gonna
draw a line here and you kind of notice
if I move the line really close when I
do my setting on the bottom of the stone
I try to make it just a little bit
smaller than my stone okay so what
happened I'm just gonna do a comparison
I'm gonna copy the whole things with the
gumbo hold the gumbo and then tap the
achey then you will make a copy in this
comparison I'm gonna pick up the bottom
one and just scale it a little bit
bigger as you can see from the top view
they are exactly the same stone this
decisis the same but because the metal
around they're giving a frame and make
the stone smaller and of course your
client doesn't want to see that they
want to see the stone as big as possible
alright so keep in mind that if you are
doing any of the stone setting
make sure that your seat is not over the
age of the stone and that will make your
design the stone look bigger on your
design alright thank you for watching
and I will see you next time
[Music]